there is much archaeological wonders as
they are diplomatic Dynamite the debate
over the Elgin marbles has raged for
more than 200 years but now it seems a
resolution could be approaching the
British museum for the first time
confirming it is in talks with Greece
over their possible return
as culture minister Ed vasey opposed
such a move but now as Lord vasey leads
a campaign calling for just that we've
always in this country held a pretty
intransitive position I held it as a
minister rather embarrassingly which is
that the sculptors could not return now
I think thanks to the vision of the new
Chair George Osborne We will see
something which would be a historic
moment
yes that's right George Osborne chair of
the British museum he declined our
request for an interview but in a
statement the museum said we're actively
seeking A New Path non-partnership with
our friends in Greece and as we enter a
new year constructive discussions are
ongoing
legislation prevents the Museum from
giving artifacts away so this wouldn't
be a permanent relocation instead it's
thought that a long-term loan is being
discussed a kind of cultural exchange
whereby the marbles would be sent to
Greece in return for something else
two and a half thousand years old the
marbles used to be part of the Acropolis
they were taken to Britain in the early
19th century by a diplomat called lord
Elgin hence their name but to Greeks
they're still known as the Parthenon
sculptures and talk of their return is
huge
it's in the DNA it's the soul of every
Greek it represents what Chris was what
Greece what we remember Greece said to
have been and what we're aspiring to so
it is of vital importance
but for those against restitution even
alone isn't palatable arguing that it
sends Britain and others down a slippery
slope
if we decide that by virtue of their
cultural
significance anything to do with their
legal property status goes out of the
window and it's a second order a kind of
line of reasoning these puts in
developerly the whole framework upon
which museums operate
the government says it's a matter for
the Museum's trustees whatever they
decide the debate over where these items
belong is sure to continue
either Bennett Sky News